as this is our final episode of the year
we wanted to thank you so much for
watching we had a lot of fun despite you
know the world we've started a crisis
pregnancy center we had Wilmer
Valderrama in a bird suit we wrote a
book about Mike Prince's rabbit and you
bought it we built it a lot
raising a huge amount of money for The
Trevor Project and 80 90 thank you so
much for doing that season they've got
HBO's web site temporarily blocked in
China whoops
we talked to Anita Hill about her
experiences and they depressingly
prescient interview we put Gritty on our
dog Supreme Court but a quick update
about my personal favorite moment from
this year because by now you probably
know that we sometimes like to buy
stupid things um for instance last year
we bought five wax presidents at Carter
Nixon Harding Clinton and Harrison and
we made a movie about the life of warren
g harding with Laura Linney we actually
promised you that we would try and find
a way to use the rest of the presidents
but we never probably got around to it
well this year we bought something even
dumber because when Russell Crowe held
his divorce auction we bought a bunch of
his memorabilia including his jockstrap
from the 2005 film Cinderella Man which
we then donated to one of the last
blockbusters in Alaska and to his
immense credit Russell Crowe used the
money that we paid to fund the John
Oliver koala chlamydia Awards at the
Australia Zoo which is that is a burn so
hard that only koalas with chlamydia can
sympathize
it was a truly life-affirming sequence
of events although I'm sorry to say that
I do have a sad update on the Alaskan
blockbuster part of that story alaska's
last two blockbuster video stores are
calling it quits Jon Oliver tried to
draw a little attention to these stores
to save them he gave them a leather jock
strap that Russell Crowe wore the movie
Cinderella Man would call attention to
sure incredibly that did not have first
you just a little bit but you know
it is very sad although I will be honest
I didn't really expect the jock strap to
save blockbuster completely as amazing
as Russell Crowe's led the scrotum
holster is I didn't really think it had
the power to make Netflix disappear now
if you are wondering what happened to
all of Russell Crowe's merchandise I
have good news and bad news the good
news is there's actually one remaining
blockbuster in America it's in Oregon
and all the items were sent there the
bad news is one of them went missing and
tragically it was the jock strap though
there were actually numerous stories
about its disappearance and and I am
sorry to tell you that we have no idea
where Russell Crowe's jockstrap is we
don't we simply don't except for the
fact that we actually do in fact not
only do we know where that jockstrap is
we asked ourselves what would be the
single dumbest possible way to pay
tribute to the most wonderfully stupid
thing that happened this year and the
answer we hope you will agree was this
all right listen up we've robbed banks
museums casinos this this is the big one
greatest heist of all time we're gonna
steal Russell Crowe's jock strap from
the 2005 film Cinderella man
[Music]
[Applause]
this won't be easy that's why I've hired
the best of the best
tricky dick the best damn explosives man
in New York City
Jimmy see no bees mr. Fixit himself has
no ride he can't chop
Willie pneumonia sick man with a sick
rap sheet
Billy wheels the man with the master
[Music]
actually I'm not really sure what he
does and of course our ringleader the og
himself
g-dog like I said this won't be easy it
could get messy they're gonna throw
everything they got at us
you ready to do this buckle up
these guys are everywhere cover me
the hell that come from
[Applause]
that's how it's done
[Music]
security breach you think this is over
we have the stroke
don't you let that jockstrap get away G
dog
stay on them stay on them
[Applause]
[Music]
what the hell do these guys work for
although my pretty I've missed you
[Applause]